this is how you apply for a transition fee
if your contract is not renewed
you are entitled to extra money
in other words,
a transition fee
but of course you have to request this yourself
that's why I made a template for you
that you can screenshot
first,
it is important to indicate
that you want to claim
on the transition fee
because you are legally entitled to it
otherwise it is very important to mention
that the employer was the one
who terminated the contract
because if you agree or resign yourself
are not entitled to a transition allowance
in this paragraph I therefore refer to
the termination of my employment
and finally,
of course,
the question to your employer
whether he has this procedure
wants to set in motion
I'm going out of the picture now
so you can screenshot this email
ready for more tips
then follow the laura bast boost because I boost your career